why is ice slippery ice slippery uh I
don't know I couldn't tell you that but
you skate on it
I skate on it you know that it feels
pretty slippery doesn't it yeah it does
feel slippery but you would feel a
different slipperiness to me because I
skate for a living
aha because the ratio ratio of friction
chrises air on up water frozen water so
I'm here on an ice rink in Sydney and
I've been asking people why is ice
slippery now a lot of them kind of have
the right idea they say there's a layer
of water on top of the ice but they
don't know why they think it's just
because the sun's out or because it's
warm in Sydney and the ice melts so I
wanted to know why ice is slippery where
the freezing meets the less than
freezing state it becomes a liquid so
it's the liquid on top of the frozen
state that makes it slippery kill
circuits well because it gets weapon
arena like down here it's not so wet
right yeah
oh stop oh isn't it I mean that's not
it's pretty frozen yeah what is still
slippery here the water for instance on
here will lubricate and you'll have
better sliding surface than you will
with the dry ice it's like lubrication
something I don't know lubrication
because the Sun has heated up the ice
which causes it to melt the water
particles become unstable on the top
what caused it to be wet but with the
ice be slippery even if there was no Sun
depends on the actual heat it's not the
sun's rays that does it it's the actual
temperature the real reason is when you
step on the ice you compress it a bit
and that decreases its melting point and
so we get a thin layer of water that you
can glide along that's what makes ice
slippery if you were to slide on your
belly all across the water bit you'd
obviously get very wet but you'd slide a
lot further than you would on the
why section here yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
you dry that in Brisbane during the pack
down of the event I took one of our
inflatable tubes and I didn't think I
was going to get very far because the
ice was melting I managed to slide 60
meters Wow
for my friend 10-yard run up I slid 60
meters the whole way across the ring
that's pretty impressive always well I
was very happy with the regulars going
to get that far
but it doesn't actually have to be warm
out it can be freezing cold out and you
still get the same slippery effect
because it's based on pressure not the
temperature of the outside air I'm a bad
skater yeah you want to go that summer a
race you're on a race me no let's go